well i have to ask about another big
movie that you've got coming this fall
because i'm a nerd about marvel and
marvel's the eternals um you're in that
so how cool is that
that's like uh shocking it's it's beyond
cool i think it's a miracle
and i love it that i'm in the one marvel
movie that it's completely diverse
and it's very different than all the
other ones i'm gonna love it i am such a
freak fan for all of it um and i don't
think it's crazy i i'm not behind the
scenes in the actor world or whatever so
i don't know like as far as casting but
i think it's so normal to see you in
something like that so um but you say
kelly can i ask you a question i'm sorry
yeah i know i'm not supposed to
interview interviewing you but how cool
it is
that our director for that movie
it's the second woman
that actually wins an oscar for best
director
that's amazing
that's amazing wow super proud i that no
that's amazing that's incredible
animation
exactly and it's like such such great
progress like i think sometimes we get
you know kind of bummed out a bit as
females too like in as far as equal pay
and other things like in the
entertainment industry and it's really
cool when we like focus on that the
positive things like that that's really
cool i cannot wait to see it i'm very
excited no joke everyone here will tell
you i'm a nerd about marvel stuff so um
but i adore you even more which is so
annoying i don't know i it's like god
had the greatest day in all the lands
when he made you um
i'm just saying
that might be the best compliment i've
ever had you topped every dude that
tried to pick me up
i'm gonna tell every dude i know that
and i don't and i don't mean to to say
just looks either you are beautiful but
you are so fun to watch in interviews
you're so intelligent it's just i think
you have all the cards anyway i'm a big
fan
[Music]
you